[Music]
dark chocolate white chocolate biscuits
hot chocolates pralines bon bons
chocolate cake chocolate bars
from sweets to cosmetics cocoa is
everywhere
and 60 to 70 percent of it comes from
just two countries ivory coast and ghana
when you get to farmer households you'll
find that some may never even have
tasted chocolate
cocoa farmers largely live under the
poverty line of 1.25 dollars a day they
really can't even afford the finished
product
[Music]
the 100 billion chocolate industry is
plagued by child labor and has
historically been a leading cause of
deforestation in both west african
nations that receive a pittance for
selling their beans
the two countries alone represent less
than six percent of the global value
including the taxes that the country is
taking from exports the farmer is
probably getting less than two percent
but soon even these small percentages
may be lost completely as the main
importer of west african beans the
european union gears up to bangkok with
a harmful impact on the environment and
human rights if there was
legislation there that prevented west
africans from selling their cocoa there
would really be an issue for the
economies for the farmers for the
government and so that has added to i
think what was initially more of a moral
issue and made it very much an economic
issue
and these attempts by developed nations
to force a cleanup of cocoa supply chain
while potentially hurting the
livelihoods of west african farmers
might not even achieve their desired
goals
cocoa and chocolate world are stuck in
colonialism making the poor nations
poorer and the rich nations richer and
that has not changed at all
[Music]
coco a tree crop native to central and
south america was introduced to africa
over a hundred years ago
colonial powers like france and britain
compelled some of their colonies in
africa to cultivate crops that they
don't want to cultivate because of the
ecological costs
after independence these countries just
keep on producing this
raw material
which they export to
europe and america it's almost a classic
colonial division of labour
cocoa has remained intertwined with the
economies of ghana and ivory coast their
fortunes often rising and falling with
the price of the crop
after ivory coast or cote d'ivoire
gained independence in 1960 its first
president and the political elites were
cocoa growers who encouraged production
in kotovan the 1950s 1960s 70s some of
the richest men were actually cocoa
farmers
and there was a speech by the first
president saying if you want to be rich
plant cocoa
but the global price of cocoa continued
to reduce in the early 60s
to the point that in 1965 some cocoa
planters in ghana judged that it makes
no sense for them to
harvest their cocoa
the first president of ghana kwame
nkrumah had seen his country's economic
reliance on a crop with such volatile
prices as perilous
he stopped funding new cocoa farms and
then tried to diversify also try to
create
a situation whereby ghana would be
processing its cocoa unfortunately god
didn't come to fruition because of the
1960 cisco against him
the volatility of cocoa prices continued
to destabilise the ghanaian currency
and after a second coup in the 80s the
government of ghana made a pledge to its
cocoa farmers to never let the farmgate
the price it would pay farmers for their
cocoa slide below a certain threshold
so there are two prices
one is fixed by the government and one
is determined by the market
the price of cocoa on the international
markets is essentially affected by
supply and demand with most of the
supply coming from west africa and most
of the demand coming from the eu and
also north america
coco is the main export revenue for
ivory coast and the third biggest for
ghana
about 60 percent of this exported cocoa
ends up in the european union mainly in
the form of unprocessed beans
while we talk about price of cocoa
the world is changing
supply and demand
is probably not the market of tomorrow
because we have
another element which is sustainability
so we see in europe there are even right
now regulation proposals to ban cocoa
linked to deforestation
[Music]
coco's connection to deforestation dates
back decades a direct link to the
traditional method of cultivation used
in ivory coast in ghana called slash and
burn
farmers just cut down the tree and you
burn the entire land then you plant
harvest and then move to another forest
plant harvest
so after slash and bomb planting you
tend to harvest
quickly and you tend to to use less
label the problem with this is that the
amount of forest is finite so in cote
d'ivoire there's almost complete
deforestation there's no new land for
cocoa farmers to move to
to try and reduce this deforestation
ivory coast and ghana have been forcing
farmers to replant cocoa on the same
land even as the soil's nutrients get
depleted
but replanting on the same spot requires
more workers and more input to grow the
crop shrinking farmers already tight
margins
you now have to weed you don't have to
buy fertilizers pesticides second third
replanting you need to increase your use
of fertilizers so if your cost of
production keeps going up and you have
no control over the price then you have
to look for a way of deflating these
extra costs
which is one of the causes of increases
in child labor and child trafficking
this is a way of deflating cost of labor
cocoa is not an easy crop to grow and it
competes for labor with other activities
in the area like small-scale gold mining
which is often illegal and known locally
in ghana as galanze
because an el pe boy cindy claude
because of galaxies
cocoa farmers often run farms as a
family which is why
cocoa poverty is such a big issue
because a farmer would support a family
of six or eight people usually it's
small-scale farmers
so they plant in the farm and then they
come home and dry the beans before
packaging them and selling it to in
ghana's case the cocoa board through
licensed buyers
the problem with this is that
most of the benefits it's mainly in the
manufactured aspect of it why most of
the costs for example ecological cost is
mainly in the raw material aspect of it
most cocoa beans are processed once they
reach their final destination in the
factories of chocolate making companies
a study of the chocolate value chain by
oxfam showed that the grinding and
production of chocolate amounts to more
than 25 percent of the price of a bar
while in the 70s when cocoa prices hit
record highs the farmer's share was
nearly 50
today it's down to around 6 percent and
that's likely to include taxes and fees
of middlemen
so there's more middlemen they're
basically squeezing out the profit for
cocoa farmers there's one way of
explaining it
another way would be to say that there's
more consolidation
of markets power in the
chocolate production as well as the
retail part of the value chain
one other way of doing it
is to look at the cost of production the
cost of producing cocoa now and the cost
of producing cocoa
in the 1960s and 1970s it's
it's not even close
[Music]
a new cocoa is demanded in the market
cocoa produced sustainably and we need
to ensure
that anyone
that feel that sustainability is just
about deforestation is not the case
deforestation
or any human right abuse
seeing in the cocoa sector are the
consequence of poverty
and we need to tackle the root cause
to tackle farmer poverty the government
of ivory coast in ghana introduced an
initiative in 2019 called a living
income differential or lid which
requires confectionary companies to pay
a premium of 400 us dollars on each
tonne of cocoa they buy
this money is then incorporated into the
farmgate price to bring a bigger slice
of the bar to the farmer
in the first year of the lid the
farmgate price in both countries
increased nearly 20 percent
the world cocoa foundation that brings
together companies representing 80
percent of the global cocoa market has
welcomed the change
this new tool is really effective in
getting farmers out of poverty we think
that it is not possible to sustain the
the cocoa industry at the detriment of
the farmers so it's not a nice thing to
do actually it is the right thing to do
if you want to sustain the cocoa
industry for the benefits of all the
members of the supply chain
a coco farmer
your income increases by 20 you are now
happy and yes there's more money in
cocoa so if you're thinking of leaving
cocoa there's no point living now the
inevitable outcome of this would be an
increase in outputs
so an increase in output would mean a
further reduction in market price
and in fact in the last cocoa season
with in ghana's case it had a record
production actually
so there was actually over supply and so
that also gave less negotiation room
in terms of
fixing pricing with the main
buyers so this is actually good for
cocoa buyers for multinationals who want
more cocoa
but i think it should be bad for kotova
and ghana in the long run
in an effort to clean up the supply
chain governments have also been trying
to create mechanisms to ensure the
traceability of beans to the farm where
they were grown
ultimately that would be the first step
if we can trace the cocoa
that would help make for a cleaner cocoa
industry and coke cleaner cocoa supply
chain where
all the stakeholders along that supply
chain can be held responsible
so that will be really the quickest fix
to put it that way even though it's
taken a while but the bigger opportunity
really is to improve industrialization
and manufacturing
there would be a way of breaking it new
colonial patterns of trade so to break
that chain would be
to
process the raw materials in africa
before your spot
african economies have been locked in
similar trading patterns with other
commodities like crude oil or cotton
exporting raw materials for a low cost
and then importing finished goods
but a growing taste for chocolate and a
rising middle class provides an
opportunity to keep more of the value of
coco within africa
and so in ghana's capital accra an
industry of artisanal chocolate makers
has taken root
it's a work of passion i've fallen so
much in love with cocoa and chocolate
when i started it was very difficult to
get information on cocoa processing and
chocolate production
i had to go to the uk to learn how to
use the chocolate
however in the last six years there's a
growing
small industry
i think it's important that now the
current administration is pushing the
eating of
chocolate and cocoa products
bioco treats is a boutique chocolate
brand that caters to emerging local
appetites but it hasn't always been a
smooth ride
access to affordable funding you know
it's just about non-existent
so the company cannot grow maybe as
quickly as it should
to have an impact on the wider chocolate
industry change needs to happen on a
larger scale
hendrick rimers is the founder of ghana
based chocolate maker faire freak
with no bank willing to fund what was
perceived as a risky project his company
went online to crowdfund a factory
it was built in less than half a year
and has the capacity to produce four
million bars of chocolate a month
currently the advantages of producing
chocolate in west africa are not all
that many
rather to the contrary we do face a lot
of infrastructure challenges where we
are producing here
we had to bring our own internet we have
to supply our own water own electricity
most of the time we depend on our own
wastewater management so technically
speaking it would be much easier to
produce chocolate in europe where all
that infrastructure is already set up
the choice of producing in rural ghana
is one to make a statement and to show
the world that we can make world-class
chocolate here where the cocoa grows as
well
farrah freak is the only large-scale
factory in ghana producing chocolate for
export but the company's ambition is to
grow the domestic industry so it can
compete in the international market
we set up a chocolate rescue where we
train local talents in
the art of praline making
we exported the first shipment of
pralines which the students have made
after a year of training
and one of the
trainers that is the same quality that
we have made in belgium so that was one
of the proudest moments i've ever seen
you know people seeing that they are
getting that kind of comparison having
made like the same quality that is
produced in switzerland and in belgium
here in rural ghana i think that's a
significant game changer
the company aims to source everything
within the african continent and the
reasonably long shelf life of commercial
chocolate has allowed farafree to
overcome supply chain issues
but despite the appeal of this model
none of the multinational companies have
followed suit
the real reason that we see very very
little infrastructure in terms of adding
value to to resources
are the tariff kind of policies of
europe that have always said you can
bring in your commodities without any
duties paid but if you've made something
out of it be it semi-finished products
like coco mass or cocoa butter or even
chocolate finished products then duties
have applied so you've immediately been
at a cost disadvantage and it forced all
the value addition to commodities
towards or into europe and only since
around like 20 years that has been
changed and the playing field was
leveled
if you consider this very issue of local
processing
it is reflective of the set of
regulations that has been put in place
depending on the way the government is
adjusting the regulation maybe
tomorrow's picture would be different
government for example is pushing to
having national investors in it but is
considering to reach out first to the
private sector and try to reach the
win-win agreement
i think politically in the spirit of
african self-sufficiency
africa rising the idea is one that
anyone can really easily embrace but the
practice of it is one that's difficult
to implement
the more components there are in your
products the more standards you have to
meet the fact that you can just export
raw beans and get your dollars the
quickness and ease with which you can do
that is really hard to overlook
because of the export revenue component
it means that there's always going to be
a trade-off it's not just a matter of
transforming the beans but getting it to
a point where you can export and earn
and alongside economic incentives and
regulations the role of consumers in
shifting the whole industry shouldn't be
underestimated
as history shows
consumers as far back as 100 years have
forced cadbury to source their cocoa
from ghana where slavery was already
abolished
the consumer is not used to the idea of
made in africa yet or made in ghana if
you tell someone made in germany that
really rings the bell that resonates and
it has a certain message and although
it kind of
looks simple to say look we're adding a
lot of value we create meaningful
well-paid jobs producing chocolate here
you only have that split second when a
consumer decides to buy chocolate and
it's been a major challenge but we've
done
a lot in terms of explaining that
almost everyone loves chocolate but it's
important to ensure that it's cleaner
less heavy on the environment but also
fairer on the people that actually toil
the land
[Music]
you